on june 20th 2020 in tulsa oklahoma at
his very first campaign rally in almost
four months
donald trump and his staff stared out
into a half-empty arena in shock
and horror while there were a variety of
valid factors that could account for the
humiliating rows of empty seats
most commentators attributed the abysmal
rally turnout to an unlikely culprit
k-pop stands some have been baffled by
yet another plot twist to 2020
in which an army of fans have become
anonymous 2.0
but if you've been paying attention the
rise of k-pop fandoms as an unstoppable
force for social activism
is less surprising than it may seem
many attribute k-pop's origin to the
three-person group sateji and boyz
who performed on live tv as part of a
talent competition in 1992.
after their appearance they became a
sensation in south korea
propelling forward a commercial agenda
of homegrown korean talent
by the early 2000s kpop artists gained
popularity in countries like japan
china and taiwan and by 2009 wonder
girls became the first k-pop artist to
make it on the billboard hot 100.
however most credit size 2012 novelty
hit condom style
as the first actual break-in to the
american mainstream that same year
kyon bonku director of the korea
creative content agency
described the growing phenomenon saying
youtube has really changed the awareness
of k-pop
both american kids and second generation
korean-american kids are discovering it
by nature the global community of k-pop
fans was created by the internet
to exist on the internet and is still
their best tool to connect
despite the fact that kpop artists don't
get much radio play their popularity in
the us has continued to grow due to
social media and streaming
eventually the music industry could not
ignore the viral potential
of including k-pop acts in the events
like award shows bts became the first
korean group to perform at the american
music awards show in 2017.
by 2018 they returned to the show
winning the favorite social artist
on top of also winning the top social
artist award at the billboard music
awards that year
by 2019 bts won three amas and came home
with the second most awards of the night
today the kpop industry is estimated to
be worth over five billion dollars
globally and banned valve arenas around
the world in minutes
and the industry only continues to grow
as k-pop artists collaborate with even
more popular us musicians
creating crossover amongst fan bases and
while fandom is nothing new
k-pop fans have perhaps surpassed the
devotion of any other in the past
many experts attribute the first modern
phantom to the popularity of arthur
conan doyle's character
sherlock holmes when holmes was killed
off in a short story in december 1893
as many as 20 000 readers cancelled
their subscriptions and even more wrote
letters to the publisher voicing their
outrage eight years later after
continued pressure from the public and
his publishers doyle brought holmes back
in the form of his infamous prequel the
hound of the baskervilles
he followed that up with a new series of
short stories called the return of
sherlock holmes which brought the
character back to life for good
kpop fans have since evolved to become
the greatest marketing force behind
their favorite bands
not only organizing promotion across
social media but they even buy out
billboards themselves
taking over some of the most expensive
advertising real estate times square
however fandoms don't just work together
to promote their idols
they also do charity work funding many
projects around the world dating back to
at least 20 years ago
korean idols have encouraged fans to not
send gifts and instead give their money
and energy to charities
their loyal fans follow philanthropic
orders sparking the community's
involvement with social activism
20 years later that spirit remains but
has evolved into a deft force of
community organizing
they overpower award shows especially
those that require fan participation
like voting
ensuring wins for their beloved artists
with scientific precision they learn to
use algorithms to their advantage
and pump social media with hashtags to
make sure their favorites are always
trending
typically kpop fandoms deliberately make
hashtags trend to hype new music
releases
in 2019 blackpink were the female k-pop
group to perform at coachella
and the band has a huge following
on may 28 2020 just three days after
george floyd was killed
lady gaga released her newest album
chromatica featuring a must-anticipated
collaboration with blackpink called sour
candy
while many were excited for the release
increasing the group's mainstream
exposure
instead blackpink fans united to stop
hashtag sour candy from trending
helping black lives matter to remain
centered and trending this would give
way to a series of hashtag takeovers
kpop fans also infiltrated hashtags like
white lives matter blue lives matter and
whiteout wednesday
in an effort to make it more difficult
for white supremacists and sympathizers
to promote their agenda and find one
another
just a few days later k-pop activists
struck again
on may 30th the dallas police department
announced on twitter that people would
report illegal activity from the
protests using their iwatch dallas app
in response k-pop stands organized to
spam the app with fan cams
or short clips of kpop performances
which historically k-pop fans used to
spam twitter
calls to action included tweets like
download the app and
flood that [ __ ] with fan cams make it so
hard for them to find anything besides
our faves dancing
by may 31st the app was temporarily shut
down though the police department did
not comment on what caused the app to
shut down which brings us to june 4th
2020 the day bts tweeted out their
solidarity with the black lives matter
movement stating
we stand against racial discrimination
we condemn
violence you i and we all have the right
to be respected
we will stand together adding at the end
hashtag black lives matter
later this week bts and the record label
donated one million dollars directly to
the organization
haley scales blm's managing director
said on their contribution
black people all over the world are in
pain at this moment from the trauma of
centuries of oppression
we are moved by the generosity of bts
and allies all over the world who stand
in solidarity in the fight for black
lives moreover in response k-pop
devotees announced that they had raised
an additional 1 million dollars to the
organization to match bts's donation
we told you the bts army does not play
emboldened then by the momentum of
activism and their favorite idol
standing in solidarity
k-pop stans decided to take on donald
trump when trump's presidential campaign
posted a tweet inviting supporters to
register for free tickets to the tulsa
rally k-pop stands co-opted the link
realizing that you could reserve seats
and not show up spreading the word
through social media their message
ultimately went viral on several
platforms including tick tock mary jo
lop from fort dodge iowa posted a tick
tock on the subject receiving
700 000 likes and over 2 million views
and she believes that at least 17
000 tickets were reserved based on the
comments she received
many users deleted their post within 24
to 48 hours hoping to keep the trump
campaign in the dark
and obviously it worked as the campaign
was astounded that their anticipated
crowd of 100
000 supporters couldn't even fill the 19
000 seat arena
youtuber elijah daniel who participated
in the prank said of the social media
activism
these kids are smart and they thought of
everything and when he calls them kids
he isn't hyperbolizing tick tock's
largest demographic are 13 to 17 year
olds a group that can't vote but are
making their civic voices heard
regardless
but the kpop community is far from
perfect and as a group they're still
learning
growing and coming to terms with their
own inherent racism
in 2018 racism within the bts army came
to light as black members spoke out
about the harassment and erasure they
experienced using hashtags like
black army's equality and black armies
matter moreover k-pop idols are often
critiqued for appropriation
and even more insidious examples of
racism like blackface
though often cultural commentators say
there's a learning curve when it comes
to handling race outside of korea's
largely homogeneous culture
however in an increasingly globalized
world excuses of ignorance are
increasingly weak profiting from black
culture without honoring the history or
giving due credit to black artists
is no longer excusable kpop star ciel
wrote on instagram of the black lives
matter movement
artists directors writers dancers
designers producers stylists and the
kpop industry
are all inspired by black culture
whether they acknowledge it or not
i would like to encourage kpop fans to
give back and show love and support for
all that we've received from black
artists
i want to explain to kpop fans fellow
asians and non-americans
who feel like they have no connection to
what's happening that we are all
connected
and if the k-pop community has anything
to say about it they're taking their
re-education and activism into their own
hands
the power of their passion was already
undeniable their communication and
organization already unparalleled it
seems like
endless possibilities for what they
might achieve on the horizon
[Music]
you